security in Rome was just as tight as
anywhere else the US president travels
all roads leading to the Vatican were
closed with Barack Obama riding in the
Beast his armored limousine inside the
Vatican the barricades gave way to the
pomp and ceremony of the Swiss Guard
sources said Obama was keen to highlight
the two leaders common ground he called
Francis and inspiration it was a coming
together of two men whose influence is
coupled with remarkable personal
charisma Obama the politician who came
from relative obscurity to become the
first african-american US president and
Francis the Latino Pope who's brought
new vigor to the Catholic Church both
have made disadvantaged members of
society a priority the talks took place
in private with the pair speaking
through interpreters some Catholics had
high hopes of what could be achieved by
the encounter I'm hoping that as a
result of the meeting there'll be a
greater peace all the world peace may
remain an elusive goal it seems the
leaders did manage to build a rapport
the meeting was scheduled to last 30
minutes but it stretched to almost an
hour afterwards Obama spontaneously
invited the Pope to visit the White
House an invitation Francis immediately
accepted